[Musik]
impulinmuseum mitten in Warschau liegt
tief unter der Erde in einem grauen
Panzerschrank ein Schatz
ausstellungskuratoren Susanna
schnev-koller schüttet ihn der Schatz
ist ein Tagebuch ein einmaliges Zeugnis
unserer Geschichte
[Musik]
geschrieben wurde es von einer jungen
Frau wir kennen nur ihren Vornamen
marilka während des Aufstands versteckte
sie sich in einem Bunker im Ghetto unter
der Erde und sie beschreibt die
Situation dort und ihre Gefühle ihre
Ängste ihre Panik
Zitat
Tagebuch seit dem frühen Morgen konnte
man Explosionen hören die Geräusche von
revolverschüssen das Knattern der
Maschinengewehre das Ghetto hat sich
erhoben ein paar hundert Männer nur mit
Revolvern bewaffnet standen auf um gegen
die Unterdrücker zu kämpfen um die Reste
der Menschenwürde zu verteidigen es ist
ein großer ein wunderbarer Moment in der
Geschichte und für die Nachwelt
diese ergreifenden Worte sind Zeugnis
eine der mutigsten Aufstände von Juden
in der Zeit des Zweiten Weltkriegs
am 19 April 1943 haben sich einige
hundert Juden in der Hölle des
warschauers Ghettos erhoben knapp vier
Wochen dauert die eheonische Kampf gegen
die Übermacht der deutschen einiger
für die jüdischen Kämpferinnen und
Kämpfer ist völlig offensichtlich dass
die Deutschen auf die totale Vernichtung
aller Juden abzielen und vor diesem
Hintergrund sagen sie wir haben
eigentlich keine Chance Arbeit wird uns
nicht retten Flucht ist für 50.000
Insassen das Warschauer Ghettos völlig
unrealistisch sieben militärisch
besiegen werden wir die deutschen
sowieso nicht also was tun wir wir
müssen für unsere Ehre kämpfen wir
wollen mit der Waffe in der Hand sterben
wir wollen nicht einfach nur vergast
werden sondern wir möchten als Kämpfer
als Menschen und mit Würde kämpfen
doch bis es zu dem bewaffneten Aufstand
im April 1943 kommt ist es noch ein
langer und leidvoller Weg für die Juden
in Warschau
das Warschauer Ghetto drei Kilometer
Hölle mitten in der Stadt im Herbst 1940
haben die Nazis die Warschauer Juden
gezwungen in das Gebiet des sogenannten
jüdischen wohnbezirks umzusiedeln eine
gut drei Meter hohe Mauer mit
stacheldrahtkrone um grenzt das Gebiet
im Ghetto herrschen enge Hunger
Krankheit und Angst durch gezielte
Unterversorgung der über 400.000 Juden
darunter viele Frauen Kinder und Alte
breiten sich Typhus und Fleckfieber aus
in den kommenden anderthalb Jahren
verhungern 100.000 Juden im Ghetto oder
sterben an solchen und Krankheiten
zeitgleich beginnen die Deutschen mit
Deportationen der Ghetto Bewohner in die
Vernichtungslager
allein in den Gaskammern von treblinker
werden 280.000 Juden aus dem Warschauer
Ghetto ermordet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im April 1943 leben nur noch etwa 50.000
Menschen im sogenannten jüdischen
Wohnbezirk sie sind zutiefst verängstigt
und geschwächt trotzdem vermehrt sich
jetzt hier der bewaffnete Widerstand
der jüdische Untergrund ist der in
Zellen organisiert das sind auch nicht
viele wir haben hier weit weniger als
1.000 Kämpfer und bei diesen 1000
Kämpfern hat längst nicht jeder eine
Waffe die allerwenigsten haben
tatsächlich eine Waffe sie haben
vielleicht Molotow-Cocktail sie haben
ein paar Pistolen es gibt Gewehre es
gibt vielleicht auch ein oder zwei
Maschinengewehre aber es gibt nichts was
man wirklich den deutschen Panzern der
deutschen Artillerie sogar der deutschen
Luftwaffe die auch Angriffe fliegt
entgegensetzen kann das wissen die
natürlich auch vorher aber sie kämpfen
trotzdem
Katerina Jankowska arbeitet auch für das
Museum sie zeigt die wichtigsten Orte in
der Stadt wo heute noch Spuren des
bewaffneten Kampfes der Juden zu sehen
sind
ieren
genau hier war ein Tor in
Sketch am 19 April 1943 ist hier die SS
ins Ghetto gestürmt
der jüdische Widerstand hat die Nazis
angegriffen die Soldaten haben damit
nicht gerechnet sie waren von dem
Angriff der Aufständischen völlig
überrascht die jüdischen Kämpfer haben
von den Dächern auf die SS gefeiert und
das war genau hier vor 80 Jahren oder
gesagt
Anführer des bewaffneten jüdischen
Widerstands ist mordeshei an elevich er
organisiert den Guerilla Kampf gegen die
übermächtigen deutschen
ausgerüstet sind die jungen Helden mit
Revolvern und einigen wenigen Gewehren
die haben sie auf dem Schwarzmarkt
gekauft
damit und mit selbstgebauten
Molotow-Cocktails die sie von den
Dächern werfen gelingt es ihnen die
völlig überraschten deutschen zu stoppen
mit Einbruch der Nacht zieht sich die SS
aus dem Ghetto zurück auch in den
folgenden Tagen können die jüdischen
Kämpferinnen und Kämpfer den deutschen
Truppen erhebliche Verluste zufügen
danach geht den Widerstandskämpfern die
Munition aus natürlich sind auch die
ersten ihre Kämpferinnen und Kämpfer tot
und was sie dann machen ist hinhalten
der Widerstand sie ziehen sich zurück in
die vorbereiteten Bunker im Grunde lebt
das halbe Ghetto nur noch in Verstecken
und den Bunkern und sie hoffen und beten
dass sie nicht von den deutschen
entdeckt werden und wenn die Deutschen
zum Bunker kommen dann schießen Sie
vielleicht noch auf den aber sehr viel
mehr können Sie dann auch gar nicht mehr
machen sie haben keine Möglichkeit mehr
zu kämpfen unter dem Kommando von Jürgen
Stroop geht die SS nun gnadenlos gegen
die Widerstandskämpfer vor Haus im Haus
des Ghettos wird mit fl davon
niedergebrannt
die in Kellern und Bunkern Schutz suchen
den Juden werden an Ort und Stelle
erschossen oder ein Arbeitslager
deportiert am 8 mai dringen die
SS-Truppen bis zum unterirdischen
Hauptquartier des jüdischen Widerstands
in der miwashstraße 18
vorhiding
die jüdischen Kämpfer hören Schritte vor
ihrem Bunker sie wissen dass sie Nazis
sie jetzt entdeckt haben
einer der Anführer fordert alle Kämpfer
auf sich selbst zu erschießen
es ist ihre freie Entscheidung wie sie
sterben möchten nicht der deutschen
Täter
und dann hat der jüdische Widerstand im
Bunker Suizid begangen
Anfang Mai steht fast das gesamte Ghetto
in Flammen die deutschen Truppen holen
die letzten Überlebenden Zivilisten aus
den Ruinen und Kellern die Juden werden
zusammengetrieben und in Arbeitslager
deportiert
[Musik]
ist der Gullideckel
Anfang Mai sind hier die letzten 40
Kämpferinnen und Kämpfer aus dem
brennenden Ghetto durch die Kanalisation
geflohen
gleich hier hat der Lastwagen gewartet
und sie in die Wälder vor Warschau
gefahren dort haben sie sich versteckt
Marika die junge Frau die das Tagebuch
geschrieben hat kann nicht fliehen sie
wird von den deutschen aller
Wahrscheinlichkeit nach in das
Vernichtungslager mydanic deportiert
dort verliert sich ihre Spur nur ihre
Aufzeichnungen werden nach dem Krieg auf
dem Gelände des Lagers gefunden
das Zeugnis für den Helden Mut der
jüdischen Kämpfer
nur sehr wenige Juden aus Warschau haben
den Terror der Nazis überlebt aber der
todesverachtende Mut und der Kampf ist
Wille der Aufständischen ist noch heute
Vorbild für alle Juden
der Staat Israel gebaut ist weil hier
Juden sich verteidigt haben und Israel
dafür steht das Juden sich auch in
Zukunft verteidigen werden und nie mehr
wehrlos sind und so bleiben die Helden
das Warschauer Ghettos auch 80 Jahre
nach dem Aufstand und vergessen
[Musik]